♪ ♪
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
2020 ROUNDUP.
AFTER COMPLAINING ABOUT TRUMP'S
TWEETS, BEGGING FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S ACCOUNT TO BE
SUSPENDED.
JUAN, DON'T YOU THINK THIS LOOKS
WEAK?
>> Juan: NO, THEY SHOULD HAVE
SUSPENDED HIS ACCOUNT LONG AGO
FOR BREAKING THE RULES.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF YOUR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
THEY DON'T PLAN TO SUSPEND THE
PRESIDENT.
HIS BASE WOULD SAY, "OH, THEY
ARE ALWAYS PICKING ON THE RIGHT.
THEY ARE ALWAYS PICKING ON
TRUMP."
GET OUT OF HERE.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
I WILL SAY THAT I THINK HARRIS
IS TRYING TO STIR IT UP.
ELIZABETH WARREN WENT AFTER
FACEBOOK.
I THINK THAT WHAT YOU GET IS
KAMALA HARRIS SAYING, I HAVE TO
GO AFTER TWITTER.
THERE IS A LOT OF ANGER GOING
INTO 2020.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE NEVER GOING
TO SUSPEND THEM.
>> IT'S ZUCKERBERG, BY THE WAY.
SHE IS LIKE, "OH, I'M GOING TO
GO AFTER TWITTER, BECAUSE
ELIZABETH WARREN HAS SUCKED ALL
THE OXYGEN OUT OF THE ROOM.
SHE IS STANDING UP AND SAYING,
I'M GOING TO GO OUT ON FACEBOOK.
I'M GOING TO GO AFTER ALL THESE
BIG TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES.
MAYBE BY SUCKING UP TO SOME OF
THESE TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES, SHE
THINK SHE CAN GET SOME MONEY
FROM THEM.
>> Jesse: THE LAST TIME WE
COVERED HER WAS WHEN SHE KNOCKED
OUT JOE.
THE COACHES GOT TO FIGURE OUT
SOME WAY TO PUNCH THROUGH THE
NEW CYCLE.
IT'S VERY STRANGE TO ME TO HAVE
SOMEONE WHO IS RUNNING TO BE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THAT WANTS TO.
HIS TWEETING IS LIKE THEIR BEST
ASSET.
YOU GO AROUND.
PEOPLE ARE LIKE, I WISH YOU HE
WANTED TO TWEET.
IF HE STOPS TWEETING, WHO IS HE
GOING TO RUN AGAINST?
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
>> Greg: SHE HAS COME A LONG
WAY.
IF WE CAN'T BEAT HIM, WE BAN
HIM.
HE HAS THE BEST TWITTER GAME,
WHETHER YOU LIKE IT OR NOT, THE
BEST TWITTER GAME IN HISTORY.
HE DOES THINGS THAT HAVE NEVER
BEEN DONE BEFORE AND WILL
PROBABLY NEVER BE DONE AGAIN.
SHE WANTS HIM TO BE PUT IN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING TERRIBLE
THINGS ABOUT EVERYBODY.
TRUMP IS JUST WAY BETTER AT IT.
>> Jesse: I DIRECT EVERYBODY
IN THE AUDIENCE TO LOOK AT THAT
AFTER COMMERCIAL BREAK.
BERNIE SANDERS, CANCELING HIS
FUTURE CAMPAIGN.
HE RECOVERS FROM A HEALTH SCARE.
THE SENATOR UNDERWENT A HEART
PROCEDURE YESTERDAY AFTER
EXPERIENCING CHEST DISCOMFORT.
HE HAD A BLOCKED ARTERY.
HIS CAMPAIGN SAYS THAT HE IS IN
GOOD SPIRITS.
WE WISH HIM A STEADY RECOVERY.
HE 78 YEARS OLD.
HE'S GOT A LOT OF ENERGY, BUT HE
THINK THIS CAME AS A SURPRISE TO
EVERYBODY.
>> Greg: IS HE TWO YEARS
YOUNGER OR TWO YEARS OLDER THAN
MICK JAGGER?
>> Dana: TWO YEARS OLDER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
I HAVE NOTHING TO SAY.
ILLNESSES ARE INEVITABLE WHEN
YOU GET OLDER AND YOU HAVE THREE
CONTENDERS RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
OVER 70.
ONE IS NEARLY 80.
I KNOW THAT IT'S BAD FAITH
SHOULD TALK ABOUT PEOPLE'S
HEALTH, SO I WON'T UNTIL THE
BREAK.
>> Jesse: THERE ARE POLITICAL
IMPLICATIONS.
>> Dana: THERE ARE.
IT WILL BE OFF THE TRAIL FOR A
LITTLE WHILE.
THEY HAVEN'T SAID EXACTLY WHEN
HE WILL COME BACK, BUT GIVEN
THAT THIS IS A PRETTY ROUTINE
PROCEDURE, PROBABLY PRETTY
QUICKLY.
HE DID HAVE ADS THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO GO UP TODAY,
STARTING TODAY AND I WILL.
THEY HAVE PULLED THOSE.
>> Jesse: THEY HAVE RAISED A
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
>> Juan: WE'VE GOT TO WISH HIM
WELL.
I MEAN, IT'S NOT EASY.
YOU WANT TO KNOW ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH, BECAUSE YOU WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT ANY UNDERLYING CONDITIONS.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS A FUNCTION
OF HIS AGE.
I'VE SEEN VERY YOUNG PEOPLE.
SOMEONE I KNOW WHAT HAD TO HAVE
THIS DONE.
IT COMES AS A SHOCK, BECAUSE IT
REMINDS YOU OF YOUR IMMORTALITY.
HIS CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN DOING
WELL, BUT HAS HAD SOME TROUBLE.
>> I'D SAY THAT.
>> Jesse: AS A SENATOR, HE
PROBABLY HAS EXCELLENT
HEALTH CARE.
VERY GOOD CARE.
>> YEAH.
>> Jesse: BETO O'ROURKE TOOK
US TO THE DENTIST.
THEN HE WENT FOR A TRIP TO THE
BARBER TO GET A HAIRCUT.
THEN HE SHOWED US HOW TO CHANGE
A TIRE.
HE HAS A NEW SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT.
WATCH.
>> STILL CRYING.
>> THAT'S IT.
>> Jesse: I THINK THIS IS HIS
BEST ONE, BECAUSE YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO SEE YOU GETTING A
FLU SHOT, BECAUSE YOU WANT
EVERYBODY GETTING THE FLU SHOT.
>> Dana: YES.
>> NUMBER ONE, DO SOME PUSH-UPS
BEFORE YOU SHOW YOUR GUNS.
YEAH.
HE'S BEEN BUSY DRIVING A CAR AND
NOT WORKING OUT, NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, I GET STUFF SHOT IN
MY FACE AT LEAST ONCE EVERY FOUR
WEEKS.
AND A LOT OF NEEDLES.
THIS IS REALLY NOT THAT BIG OF A
DEAL.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE TERRIFIED OF
NEEDLES, AREN'T YOU?
>> IT'S FACE WORK AND I'M 50 AND
I WORK ON TV.
I DON'T CARE IF ANYBODY KNOWS I
IT.
>> Juan: I JUST GOT A FLU SHOT
FLU SHOT, AND BECAUSE I'M OVER
65, THEY GAVE ME A PNEUMONIA
SHOT.
I'VE BEEN FEELING LOW.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD THING FOR
HIM TO DO THAT.
I KNOW YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO DO
WITH THAT, BUT IT'S ALL PART OF
HIS ACT OF, I'M A REAL HUMAN
BEING.
THAT SELLS.
LOOK AT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Dana: I THINK THAT IS
BETTER THAN KAMALA HARRIS TRYING
TO BAN TRUMP ON TWITTER.
I WANT TODAY.
I GOT THE FLU SHOT.
MY HUSBAND AND I DID IT AS A
DATE.
>> AW.